[Musique]
en termes de vaccination c'est au tour
des adolescents la vaccination dès 12
ans et plus va débuter le 15 juin
emmanuel annoncé hier lors d'un
déplacement dans le lot
dans ce village du lot le chef de l'état
arrive en terrain conquis
il faut dire que 78 % des habitants ont
voté pour lui au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
vous êtes en forme d'hommage à il était
une fois à l'entrée des artistes
un petit garçon blond regard un peu
triste j'en trouve meilleur que tu
viennes il attendait de moi
une phrase magique je suis obligé de
dire la vérité au foot c'est pas vrai
c'est pas mal que le président il voir
dans le pays à quel point les gens
peuvent pas le blairer sallede comment
ce dans une période particulière autour
du virus du confinement comment draguer
c'est juste c'est bizarre non
comment draguer comment se rencontrent
et comment s'en passer et comment se
prendre la main a enfin cessé
c'est étonnant je pense qu'il faut
mentir sur sur la marchandise un beau
coup à mentir sur la marchandise elle
est belle cette formule
mais qu'elles tiennent mieux ce soir
quand on était à plus belle n'oublie pas
non mais on a le plaisir ce soir de
recevoir yann moix
merci d'être avec nous vous présente
vous êtes écrivain mais je voulais juste
te dire que suis désolé de garder mon
masque c'est que je fais une allergie
aux masques donc alors expliquez-moi
tandis que je fais une allergie aux
masses c'est pas beau à voir donc j'ai
obligé de garder le masque pour pas
qu'on voit mon allergie
oui mais donc c'est le serpent qui se
mord la queue vous exciter notre
curiosité
une allergie à les effets de voir il ya
pommade bon au goût de franchement
regardez c'est quand même pas très
agréable vous avez vu de la peau mate et
défend cette agréable par notre invité
vous avez entendu ce qu'il a dit
elephant man c'est vraiment agréable
pour d'être un vif émoi suite il va
faire un autre film de david lynch que
j'aime donc au contraire morin moi je ne
comprends pas cette société où on pense
pas des passe-temps d'énergie ton temps
à vouloir vivre à la place des autres
c'est le choix de vie de quelques c'est
son choix
s'il est heureux comme il est comme ça
tout le monde arrête parce que qahtani
est mauvais je suis dans le show oui je
vais faire des débats au short
est-ce que ça gêne non 12 à nos invités
seulement est ce que ça vous dit jojo
avec un pantalon
voilà comme ça voilà vous calmer berger
tous et j'ai fait mes tests coheed tu
vois ouais mais je le dis à personne
ok et si négatif dans huit et négatifs
par contre est positif à mon charme mais
être homosexuel ce n'est pas une maladie
quoi ceux qui sont content c'est eux qui
sont un trait sur t d hypocrite c'est
eux qui lutte contre l'homophobie ils
empêchent les autres de vivre
dieu n'a jamais envoyé qui que ce soit
quelle que soit la religion c'est là où
ça me rend complètement folle de voir
des gens qui passent pin énergie dingue
a détruit la vie des autres parce que
les gens ont décidé d'être différent
c'est en particulier les réseaux sociaux
qu'il faut surveiller
et surtout chez les filles celle qui
passeraient plus de temps aurait un plus
gros risque de dépression voire
d'automutilation alors pourquoi plutôt
les filles que les garçons les
scientifiques supposent que sur les
réseaux les filles sont plus exposés et
harcelée sur la base de leur apparence
physique ce qui affecte la confiance en
soi alors on est sur le temps d'un look
noir
je crois que tu as mis la jupe à
l'envers ma petite chloé lambert et
villages ou la fermeture est là derrière
mme écoulé d'où vient au vasco de gama
bien de la voix la raison et je finis
période et portugal
c'est comme pedro tout ça là le truc
comme ça allez c'est super simple il
songe à mal à barcelone pour pastor que
servir du portugal vasco de gama
[Musique]
en plein coeur de la forêt il nous
emmène voir une piscine de déchets
toxiques terroristes tout ça c'est une
piscine de pétrole la végétation a
poussé mais regarde comme ça bouge
naphta et mobile c'est parce qu'à
l'intérieur
c'est plein de pétrole ont lieu bref ces
mots vire morosité voilà un bassin de
rétention des déchets toxiques et des
eaux usées issues de l'extraction du
pétrole
il a été creusé par l'entreprise
américaine texaco aujourd'hui de
chevreuil la multinationale a quitté
l'équateur il ya plus de 25 ans en
laissant derrière elle une nature
contaminés regardez plutôt depuis le 19
mai dernier les habitants les plus
fortunés d'une résidence de la capitale
britannique peuvent nager dans ce bassin
transparent perché à 35 mètres du sol
une première mondiale
de quoi avoir le tournage en
impressionnera c'est effrayant
c'est une oeuvre vendue près de 15000
euros aux enchères vous ne voyez rien
normal io sono je suis est une oeuvre
invisible créé par un artiste italien
une métaphore de l'époque que nous
vivons fait savoir salvatore garau en
janvier le peintre et sculpteur de 67
ans a exposé une structure de ce type
intitulé bouddha en contemplation devant
la scala à milan
une autre sera bientôt installé à new
york bisous aux fidèles joueurs et vous
tirez cette énergie douce hedrick c'est
fou à la pêche quoi les fruits les
fruits et le croque la fesse de la
personne de ton choix
troc la fumée des trucs à s'installer
vas-y enlève dans certains cas les gars
j'ai grave kiffé dans la série télévisée
drôles de dames toulon connaît créant 76
quel était le prénom de charlie hoya 6
pour ceux qui ont raté début d'émission
le secret de la forme c'est excellent et
bingo et les fruits à des fruits et les
fruits la pectine comme dirait jean
claude c'est là où je disais non mais tu
veux dire après un petit mot non mais tu
sais moi c'est pas possible je dit radan
le silence a pas là pour la santé oui ça
m'intéresse conduite sans arrêt bruit et
sans ces différents 1
le bruit c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas décidé et les sons c'est quelque
chose qu'on gérard quelqu'un qui dit bon
bah faut bakker